the subject of today's list is an
actress that has many accolades
including a Best Actress Oscar and has
played an array of roles and done them
well each and every time she's got a
real Home on the Range if you know what
I mean and if you don't know what I mean
what I'm trying to say is that her range
is so vast she has more than enough
certified fresh films to fill a top 10
list many of them comedies which isn't
always easy and on top of it all she's
just 35 years old so take that father
time and since all the b-roll has
already given it away I really should
have thought that one through I'm
talking about Emma Stone she's great and
she's getting better how is that
possible it just is so here are the top
10 Emma Stone movies ranked by Tomato
Meter right now on Rotten Tomatoes
[Music]
countdown starting with number 10 crudes
a new age kicking things off is this
2020 animated flake which is a sequel to
the crudes released 7 years earlier
emone was among the star sted voice
casts that returned for the second one
along with Nicholas Cage and Ryan
Reynolds Emma plays the oldest daughter
of a cave people like family who leads
away when it comes to trying new things
and she has a scars to prove it whoa
what's that Mark on your wrist oh this
is just a scar scar yeah from a thorned
crab no Mig deal wa and that razor worm
what about that one scorpion Badger
swamp snake Sky snake volcano end of the
world my little sister my little sister
my little sister she bites a lot and my
dad doesn't even know know about this
one wa peanut
toe in the second offering the crude
family finds themselves in an idealic
new Paradise to live except for one
little evolutionarily more advanced
family in their way and you try saying
that word on your first try it took me
like three evolutionarily the animation
for crudes a new age was finished up
back when Co first started and it came
out in November of 20120 but it still
managed a decent box office haul and a
Golden Globe nomination and if I had to
put my money on on it I'd say a lot of
it was thanks to Emma Stone's voice
performance number nine Crazy Stupid
Love This 2011 film stars Steve Carell's
Cal the family man who suddenly finds
himself single and over 40 so he looks
to Ryan Gosling's Jacob who's a hit with
the ladies to help him find his way and
while Jacob does help Cal learn how to
navigate the fickle world of dating it
turns out that Jacob is unknowingly
dating Cal's daughter played by Emma
Stone needless to say that makes for a
fun scene when it all comes to a head
Nana hi guys hi sweetheart hi what's
going on oh I don't know some game you
won't let me take this dumb blindfold
off Cal is that him what are you doing
here what are you doing here wait do you
guys know each other what's going on
what you doing here hey Nana hi Robbie
hey Nana hi cutie Jacob it's so nice to
meet you I've heard so many wonderful
things about you from Nana I'm sorry
what's a Nana I'm a Nana you know I
couldn't say Hannah when I was little
how do you know my dad God I love that
scene so much Stone held her own among a
loaded cast that also included Julianne
Moore and Marissa Tay so much so that
stone actually won People's Choice and
Teen Choice Awards for her performance
both comedically and otherwise and
critics loved Crazy Stupid Love for its
unabashed sweetness and terrifically
talented cast meanwhile the rest of us
love it for the dirty dancing style lift
that Ryan Gosling and Emma Stone do I
mean it is so
smooth number eight Battle of the Sexes
this 20177 Sports film is Loosely based
on the 1973 tennis match between Billy
Jean King who's played by Emma Stone and
Bobby rigs played by Steve Carell their
second time working together after Crazy
Stupid Love so it's kind of funny that
this movie is up next some critics
called it the best performance of
Stone's career up to that point in part
because it was against the norm of what
Young Hollywood actresses were doing at
the time and I mean she totally
transforms herself ladies and gentlemen
this is kuster's last stand this is the
lobber versus the
lever
keep talking Bobby more nonsense you
spell the worst it's going to be when
you lose well I'm the ladies number one
I'm the champ why would I lose because
dinosaurs can't play
tennis potential schedule conflicts
briefly put Brie Larson in the role of
Billy Jean instead but Emma worked it
out and ran with the role she met with
Billy Jin King to prep and also studied
old interview footage to get King's
accent and Tennis style down Emma also
so put on 15 lbs via some high calorie
protein shake which kind of sounds
really good all of a sudden number seven
easa this teen romcom from 2010 was
inspired by the 1850 novel The Scarlet
Letter by Nathaniel Hawthorne the 1850s
I mean talk about a throwback it
features Emma Stone in the lead role as
a buttoned up young lady named Olive who
decides to spice up her boring weekend
Story by telling her friend that she
actually lost her vCard even though she
didn't but that lie ends up spreading
courtesy of a character played by Amanda
bindes and the school starts to view
Olive in a whole new light one that she
actually Embraces hey Anon hey I just
realized the funniest thing my name is
an anagram for I love what's a what's an
anagram look at that big
boy what's your problem you really want
to know what my problem is no that was a
rhetorical question I don't want to know
anything from you we are not friends
anymore oh we are officially over oh
rats hey I want my juicy swier back was
way too Loser run your chest anyway ooh
burn with the help of Veteran actors
like Stanley Tucci Patricia Clarkson and
Lisa kudro Emma Stone was a hit with
critics who called her quote
irresistibly Charming which is so
accurate and that's made even more
impressive by the fact that she actually
ad lived some of the more memorable
lines during filming too according to
director wil Gluck and sure enough she
got a Golden Globe nomination for best
actress in a comedy or musical
number six super bad this 2007 comedy
marked the film debut for Emma Stone who
plays a high school student named Jules
now written by Seth Rogan and Evan
Goldberg and Loosely based on their own
experiences the film follows two high
schoolers played by Michael Sarah and
Jonah Hill who are trying to have a very
memorable night and Jules is a love
interest for the latter trying her
darnest to be cool about it all you're
like the coolest person that's ever
talked to me I thought we'd both be
drunk what does me being drunk have
anything to do with it getet with me if
you were sober look at
you look at me Seth come on you didn't
blow
it I think
maybe what the help me now Emma Stone
actually won the title of exciting new
face at the now defunct young Hollywood
awards for her role in this and since
that fact is kind of weak uh I should
probably also mention that super bad
which was a box office success is
considered one of the the best comedies
of the 2000s and it uses the fword 176
times across 113 minutes with an average
of 1.6 f-words per minute and it's
probably the reason Jonah Hill has a
screen time record for curse words over
Samuel Jackson which I don't think
Jackson's too happy about okay friends
so we're halfway there and I love a good
recap so just to get you up to speed it
was crudes a new age at 10 Crazy Stupid
Love at N9 Battle of the Sexes at 8 easa
at 7 and super bad being super awesome
at number six so what exactly is going
to be in the top five well I can tell
you that certified fresh flicks like
kruella and The Amazing Spider-Man
aren't on there so hopefully you're more
intrigued and here we
go number five Zombie Land directed by
Ruben fer in his feature debut this 2009
flick follows a group of survivors as
they travel cross country seeking safer
ground after a virus turned most people
into zombies now along with Woody
harelson and Jesse Eisenberg Leading The
Way Emma Stone stars as witch the older
sister of Abigail brin's character who
is also her partner in con artist
crime I love you I love you
[Music]
too you need some help nothing you
mention it we'll take your weapons your
car keys your ammunition and if you got
it sugarless cup what the Zombie Land
would become the top grossing zombie
movie in the United States until World
War Z took the crown in 2013 but of
course that was good enough for a sequel
so Zombie Land double tap with emone and
the others returning got even more
praise from critics and more dollars
from movie
goers number four La La Land This 2016
musical dramedy was written and directed
by Damen chazelle and it stars Ryan
Gosling as a struggling jazz pianist and
Emma Stone is an inspiring actress in La
now it was actually a pretty perfect
role for Emma who herself became an
aspiring actress in La at the age of 15
so she was actually able to put a lot of
her own knowledge into the performance
plus she said that she's loved musical
since seeing lay murab at the age of 8
and actually first met director chazelle
while she was making her Broadway debut
in Cabaret in 2014 I guess he saw
something you're the
to ready do what you need to do till
they discover you and make you more than
who you're seeing now for with the I
think I'll stay behind you got to go
[Music]
and that's someone in the
crowd so Miles Teller and Emma Watson
were originally slated to star in this
film but they both dropped out to pave
the way for Ryan Gosling and Emma Stone
good thing because the result was La La
Land grossing almost $450 million at the
worldwide box office and being nominated
for 14 Academy Awards while winning six
including best director for 32-year-old
chazelle the youngest ever at the time
and best actress for Emma
Stone number three Birdman or the
unexpected virtue of ignorance Michael
Keaton stars in this 2014 film as a
Hollywood actor known for a superhero
role got to love when things are metal
like this now he's on the Downs slope of
his career and trying to put on a
Broadway play to stay relevant Emma
Stone plays his daughter Sam with whom
he's trying to reconnect and she's
actually a recovering drug addict
working as his assistant and well you
know the daughter SL assistant role
means telling it like it is this is my
chance to finally do some work that
actually means something that means
something to who you had a career dad
before the third comic book movie before
people started to forget who was inside
that bird costume you were doing a play
based on a book that was written 60
years ago for a thousand Rich old white
people who's only only real concern is
going to be where they go to have their
cake and coffee when it's over nobody
gives a but you Birdman which one best
picture director original screenplay and
cinematography Oscars was shot to
simulate the effect of taking place
almost all in one continuous shot it
turns out that the longest takes were
about 15 minutes and averaged in the
10-minute range Emma said that it made
it extra hard for actors when it came to
timing telling Jimmy Fallon that she
actually ruined a six-minute take by
rounding a corner a little too early and
I know what you're thinking there's no
way she could ruin anything ever because
she doesn't number two the
favorite released in 2018 this dark
comedy finds Emma Stone in 18th century
Great Britain and there she plays one of
two cousins the others played by Rachel
Weiss who are vying to become the
favorite of a frail Queen played by
Olivia Coleman who actually won the Best
Actress Oscar for this
abigel if you forget to load the pellet
the gun fires makes a sound but releases
no
shot it is a great jape do you
agree yes maybe we will think of a use
for it one day sometimes it is hard to
remember whether you have loaded the
pellet or not I do fear confusion an
accident I'm sure people will be careful
now the favorite was directed by yoro
Lanos who apparently takes his casting
very seriously emone actually reached
out to him to get an audition and he had
her worked with a dialect coach so that
she could work freely without the accent
becoming a hindrance I guess it worked
the critics dug this one and they prais
L the most for quote getting roundly
Stellar performances from his well
chosen Stars I mean that is something to
shoot for being roundly
stellar and finally number one poor
things speaking of yorgos Lanos and Emma
Stone they are clearly a match made in
heaven because this black comedy was
directed by the former and stars the
latter with both serving as producers so
Emma Stone leads the way along with
names like Mark Ruffalo William defo
Ramy and Gerard carmichel it's based on
the 1992 novel of the same name about a
young Victorian woman who's played by
Emma Stone who is resurrected by a
scientist after committing suicide but
then she runs off with a corrupt lawyer
to really find herself these two are
fighting and ideas are banging around in
Bella's head in heart like lights in a
storm
oh you're always reading now Bella
you're losing some of your adorable way
of speaking I'm a changing aable feast
as are all of we apparently according to
Emerson disagreed with by Harry come
come just
come you were in my son the film was
just released this fall and has already
made waves I mean clearly considering
its placement on this list plus it won
the highest prize after premiering at
the Venice film festival and obviously
with such a high certified fresh Tomato
Meter score poor things is a hit with
critics who call it a bizarre brilliant
Tor to force for the director and actor
combo and okay sorry now that is
something to shoot for being bizarre and
Brilliant but obviously I would love to
be called roundly seller as well well
friends you are roundly seller and we
did it I don't know about you but this
list totally makes me want to watch
movies with Emma Stone and them I mean
she really knows how to pick roles for
more on all these movies that we discuss
today be sure to hit up rotten
tomatoes.com thank you so much for
checking out today's list until next
time I'm your host Nas Perez and we'll
see you back here for more Rotten
Tomatoes
countdown
[Music]
n